vous savez quelles sont les conséquences
étaient une étude qui est paru sur les
conséquences du confinement à long terme
et quoi est ce que vous savez que quand
même le confinement à long terme mais à
long terme il va provoquer une explosion
des cancers étudiés qui n'ont pas été
dit pas non j'ai un moment donné si vous
voulez c'est bien d'avoir une opinion
sur une étude de là dessus et tu as
fondait sur une étude des traces non ça
c'est vrai à ouidah bras ça c'est vrai
alors c'est vrai juliette oui monsieur
division alors il vous est connu mais on
reprend vous êtes pour 1 re confinement
mais oui je suis pour un confinement
parce que leur confinement est devenu
obligatoire à cause de monsieur division
et dit pas je veux dire pourquoi moi
aussi j'ai mon étude 15 juillet 2020
académie nationale de médecine
à propos du port du masque oui c'est la
mesure je cite c'est la mesure la plus
efficace pour supprimer la transmission
du virus de personne à personne à
condition qu'elles soient appliquées par
tous dans l'espace public à l'extérieur
voilà monsieur division et ont porté le
match d'hier nous parce que moi vous ne
respectez nous en saurions participation
mais on a des récentes journées font si
vous avez un peu bosser encore du
plateau ça fait évidemment vous vous
êtes arrêté au 15 juin sans prendre en
compte les études super la tiens ils
sont pris en compte le fait que halak
avec une escale de médecine n'a aucun
pouvoir de recommandation scientifique
mais c'est pas grave vous apprendrai
sanogo la blondinette et depuis vous
avez l'eau conso la république dont
c'est la mission
voilà un organe en france cette addition
c'est l'opposé de santé publique qui
vous dit que le port du masque à
l'extérieur bon c'est pas le débat ce
soir mais qu'effectivement est il
efficace et utile
le cynisme européen viens de vous le
dire c'est trop dur confinement cher
monsieur je me permet effectivement
encore une fois vous faire remarquer que
vous changer de sujet mais c'est pas la
folie des hommes avaient été obligés de
confiner et en malaisie
on va rencontrer à cause de vous
non vous l'avez compris c'est très bien
attendez attendez vous êtes parfaitement
raisonner mais en tout cas ce que je
fais est foncée que le conseil
scientifique je vous dis qu on est
gouvernés par la peur et à cause de gens
comme vous que si c'est bon tu ne lisais
rien et qu'effectivement venez pérorer
sur les plateaux télé parce que
concrètement vous ne lisiez l'erreur
vous ne comprenez rien mais alors je
suis un peu d'accord avec vous c'est
vrai que vous venez pérorer sur isabelle
venet père aurait jamais vous avez
trouvé n'a donné que vous avez passé dix
minutes va passer d'équipement trouver
une étude à laquelle je comprenais rien
et vous venez de le poser il a d'accord
sur rien et trucks défense
c'est un joli cadeau pour vous aussi je
les comprends c'est passé briller 2021
c'est une étude rétrospective depuis un
an depuis un an
l'europe a effectivement publié une
étude sur le port du masque
alors regardez où est-ce que ça a marché
parce que ça marchait pas merci pas si
vous lisez l'anglais et ses cibles les
empêche de vous l'offrir
si ça évite le contenu m'a soulagé parce
que moi je vois qu'un problème est que
la chine jouait son cas parce qu'à
l'intérieur c'est c'est grâce à moi
on attendait le mr boulaïncer bull ne
prennent pas beaucoup parlé sur les
plaques et rihanna qui agissent est ce
que pendant ce temps là pendant qu est
activement vous venez parler soit
adhérent lui qui a fait un recours
devant le conseil d'état pour les
masques à l'intérieur c'est vrai et ça a
donné quoi acs a donné quoi est basée à
thônex attendez j'ai terminé sa tournée
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps de plaider
parce que le gouvernement à changer ses
voiles a été retoqué son record des six
mois continue à tout le match aux blacks
s'est moqué des laiteries qui ne connaît
rien aux sources des bouteilles et vous
me donnez des sons tupperware